In this video, we'll look at collisions.
Oftentimes, when we're importing into Unreal Engine,
we'll have a checkbox available to us that asks
if we would like to generate missing collisions.
This will tell Unreal Engine that when we're walking around a scene,
especially in, for example, a third-person character template,
that we should bump into and not go through certain kinds of geometry.
As we see in the bottom right,
we can also have collisions set up manually,
in this case, just affecting the columns,
which is particularly useful if we have more complex geometry
above the height that a character will be able to access,
and there's no reason to have collision data there.
To give your CPU a break, it's always ideal to keep your collisions
as simple as possible, but if your platform can handle it,
there are also very simple ways to make all the geometry
just match the same collision data as the geometry itself.
Here's an example of modeling a custom collision box
over in a DCC tool.
You can see that it's much simpler than the geometry inside of it,
but will still allow more complex collisions
than something like a simple box or sphere.
These collision meshes can import into Unreal Engine automatically
as long as they follow the naming convention of the prefix
ucx underscore, full mesh name, underscore number.
Let's take a look at the collisions map in Content Maps,
where we'll see that we've got a simple wall
with a hole cut through it,
some various objects on the ground, and some columns.
So if we go ahead and start by looking at our Flayer collision,
we can see that these are already set up
in a pretty useful way that gives us a good sense
of how collisions should work.
So if we think our character is going to be able to hit the top of this wall,
of course, we want this tab collision,
whereas with the much taller columns,
we probably don't need to go above the height that the player could jump or reach to,
so this is perfectly fine.
There's no need to get into the details of every nook and cranny of these columns.
Down here, we want these, of course, to be a little bit more convex.
And so these are set up just enough to be able to block the player
in a more robust way than a simple cube or sphere would be able to.
Let's take a look at these a little bit closer.
So if I open up Cart Damaged,
and I view the collision here,
we can see that this was set up as a convex element.
So if we wanted to try creating something like this ourselves,
we could go and remove collision,
and then try doing this with auto-convex collision.
It'll ask us what we want the whole count and the max vertices to be.
I can hit apply, and it will give us something actually a little bit more detailed
than the one we just had.
If we wanted to simplify it,
we could say remove collision,
make the whole count to max-hole vertices 8,
hull precision 10,000, hit apply,
and there we are with a simpler piece of collision geometry.
This is different from the other cart over here,
where the collision data was actually brought over from its origin,
I believe in 3ds Max.
And you can see the way this was modeled
is quite different from how Unreal Engine would automatically process this kind of data.
For our simple wall,
we might want to see what the existing collision data is,
but once we click here, we'll see remove collision is grayed out.
That's because this does not actually have any collision data.
We have no primitives, no convex elements.
What's happening here is we have collision complexity
set to use complex collision as simple,
which means that it'll use the exact geometry here as collision data,
which isn't too bad because there's only 44 triangles and 76 vertices in this entire object.
It would be much more expensive if we did something like that with the colonnade here.
So we went down to the same thing and said,
collision complexity, use complex collision as simple and save that.
We could test to see that it's working with player collision.
And now we're putting a lot more load on the CPU,
even though it's very unlikely if we've got a standard third-person game, for example.
It's very unlikely a player would be encountering colliding with the cornice of the columns.
So we could go back here,
change this back to project default,
and if we wanted to, we could view the current collision
and try modeling this ourselves.
So I could select each of these and delete them,
or just to remove collision at the start of that.
And now I could go ahead and add a box or, you know, let's say to make it a little different.
Maybe I want to do a capsule because this is a little bit more rounded.
So I could do a capsule and I'd scale that down using my traditional hotkeys of Q, W, E and R.
Get this at a height.
Turn off some of my snapping, maybe.
Get this at a height that I think is reasonable for my particular use case.
Put it roughly there into the column.
It's actually a pretty good fit.
I could fine-tune this, of course, if I wanted to,
by looking in some orthographic views,
maybe in a wireframe mode, something like this.
Yeah, that looks pretty good.
I could make it a little bigger if I wanted to.
But the other thing here is I can hold down Alt and drag this out to duplicate this
and create another collider right there.
So if I go ahead and save that now,
we can now see that my new colliders, these capsules,
are existing here in place of the cubes that were there before.
In the next video, we'll look at a skeletal mesh import pipeline.